we're going to see a draw any moment now
white's knight is going to leap back
attacking the rook the rook's going to
retreat where it came from and we're
going to see this mechanism repeat
itself let's go back to the player's
cameras if napoleon actually plays this
move again it looks like we might be
headed towards the draw the position
will repeat itself three times okay so
this is the move we're looking at now
for the first game and the world
championship match 2021 to be over with
the draw it's now up to jana pomnyacci
why why is he taking now pulse to think
about this well it's the rule of every
soviet school child that you always
repeat the position once and then you
take a pause and you consider nope he's
actually gone for it and we're going to
see it the game will finish in a draw
yeah you can see on his body language
he's had enough it's been up and down
this game but
uh
it's been too much excitement for them
maybe and we're about to see a handshake
it's the first result of the 2021 world
championship it's a draw it's a draw
between the two big fighters in this
match
okay city oh we see a smile on jana
pognaat's face obviously they're talking
about the game right now yeah both
players smiling at some point there i
think they both know they had small
opportunities
both sides maybe not at their best yet
uh definitely momentum changing at
several points in this game
and uh i'm not sure who the happiest is
to be honest i think both sides will be
relieved that they didn't start this
world championship with a defeat